the jurgen experience
good it's good to be out of the loop i
think it's really wise that you live out
there i really do
i agree because you're so wild like for
a dude like you it's good to be
in a place where you see nature and it's
probably
in a way it's balancing and it's like
there's um
there's something about the the utah
mountains too like that's
that's a real mountain range yeah you
see that [ __ ]
all the time when you drive around utah
it's like it's very humbling
it's incredible it's just like you're a
[ __ ]
mm-hmm on the [ __ ] entire globe
also it's like natural art
like when you see mountains they're
natural art like if you drive through
the mountains it's like you're seeing
an art gallery like a nature it's
beautiful to look at and it's free
yeah it does something to you like it
excites you in a weird way like can you
when you can see a waterfall coming off
the side of a mountain and
everything's lush and green you see it
go into a flowing river
man that does a thing to your body it
does a thing to your brain it lights
everything up
and that's the best especially for
making music oh
that makes sense especially for making
music because it's just like
without sounding corny it's like
you you feel like you're a part of
something
bigger but you're so insignificant and
then
you can just say i accept
everything around me yeah and
i'm relaxed and i'm at peace
you know knowing that you're just
the world spinning around you and
everything happens for a reason and you
can just sit there
a hundred percent peace at ease
and say i don't have to worry you know
like i said earlier
l.a always something going on yeah i i
couldn't do it so
yeah there's and it definitely affected
my creative process
for sure what do you mean like going out
or
yeah yeah yeah there's always someone
hitting you up and
you know i don't want to speak on behalf
of everyone
in la or from l.a but there's a lot of
people who
kind of want to drain you and
well you know what it is man it's not
that they want to drain you
what it is is they're greedy they're
concentrating on themselves
and when they're concentrating on you
know they're trying to make it they're
trying to get something happening right
and they're ambitious and they're
self-centered in that way i don't mean
that
as a pejorative it's a negative thing
just they're self-centered
so they always want from you right and
so they're draining
like and when you're successful and
you're a guy who's got a lot going on
they think there's a rub i gotta get i
gotta get the post malone get that rub
right i gotta be able to somehow or
another get what he's got hey man
hit me up hey hey i'm here hey hey hey
let's do that thing
right hey hey hey hey hey hey hey let's
go out hey hey i want you to meet my
friend
right hey hey hey you're like bro i
gotta make music yeah
i'm good at one thing and that's using
auto-tune to sing
[Laughter]
you got to make that music
[Applause]